half a billion people store photos
videos and other files on Dropbox but
until recently those were sitting in
someone else's cloud Amazon's to be
exact
now Dropbox has cut out Amazon and put
the files on its own
super servers you may not notice the
change but it's an open challenge to the
Internet's biggest companies scrapping
over the multi-billion dollar cloud
computing market restoring upwards of
500 petabytes in our system that we have
designed from scratch which is known as
a magic pocket a single petabyte is a
million gigabytes the entire written
works of humankind in every single
language since the dawn of time around
50 petabytes so for us that's a couple
of racks 90% of Dropbox is data is now
running on its new system packed into
some of the most dense hard drives to
date these are over a petabyte of
storage per box and it's basically as
dense as you can physically get right
now our limiting factors is physically
how heavy these things are this you know
you're talking about the weight of a car
at least when you have a big rack of
these the boxes are so heavy that they
can only fit eight on a rack the
densities that we achieve in this
historic home weren't even possible even
a year ago it all sounds great but it's
actually a risky move for Dropbox the
company is a fraction of the size of its
competitors Amazon is Microsoft and
Google and it's faced doubt that it can
live up to its 10 billion dollar
evaluation but the pressure doesn't seem
to faze the team at the end of the day
we believe we can do is better right so
why there's again there's only a number
of companies that do this natively and
we feel like we have enough scale to do
to ourselves will it all pay off the
next few years will be crucial
game on server Lords game